This Italian company makes exact
reproductions of the renowned Winchesters
produced in the United States starting in
1866.
These lever actions were a game changer in
that era because they did away with having to
reload your rifle one cartridge at a time to
make the barrel the long tube through which
the ammunition shoots the factory starts
with a bar of solid steel that's 27
millimetres in diameter.
A computer guided circular saw slices it
into barrel length pieces.
Next, a computer guided drill bores through
the center of each barrel length bar.
The drill is fluted.
This provides a channel for a continuous
high pressure flow of cutting oil, which
breaks down the metal shavings as the drill
advances from one end of the bar to the
other. Over the course of 5 minutes, a
reamer gradually widens the bore to the
required diameter.
This takes 15 minutes.
The diameter of the barrel is what
determines a firearms caliber.
A rifle gets its name from the next
operation.
This specialized tool rifles the barrel,
meaning it carves spiraled grooves into the
barrel, bores, smooth walls.
This process takes twice as long as drilling
and reaming combined.
The grooves in the barrel put a spin on the
cartridges bullet as it exits the gun like
the perfect pass of a football.
This spin stabilizes the bullet, rendering
it more aerodynamic.
That makes the shot more accurate over a
long distance.
The next machine mils the outside of the
barrel.
This particular model has an octagonal
barrel, so the machine mills eight sides.
Another machine then makes threads on the
back end so the barrel can later screw into
the adjacent part of the rifle.
A local foundry, meanwhile, forges the
rifles.
Lever workers feed solid steel bars into a
small furnace.
The furnace temperature a blazing 1200
degrees Celsius, softens the steel in a
matter of seconds.
While the bar is still red hot.
They place it in a dye and stamp it with a
press to bend it.
Then two more pressings in a different die
to form the bent bar into the basic shape of
the lever. A fourth pressing against a razor
sharp die this
time trims the perimeter.
The roughly shaped lever is now ready for
machining in the rifle factory.
They're a computer guided mill, works at it
for 8 minutes, meticulously shaving off bits
of steel until the leavers shape is
perfected.
The mechanical section of the rifle is
called the action.
Like a lever.
It's forged out of a steel bar.
Then over the course of an hour, machined to
specifications by 100 different computer
guided tools.
This operation not only finalizes the
action's external shape.
It also hollows out areas for the internal
components, namely the rifles, lever
activated loading and firing mechanism.
But before that assembly happens, the action
takes a side trip to a metal treatment plant
where it undergoes a two step process.
First 3 minutes submerged in a hot water
bath with special salts which harden the
steel. Then a quick dip in a second bath
containing a colouring chemical.
This gives the steel an antique finish.
The action now returns to the gun factory to
rejoin the rifles, other components to
assemble the rifles, firing mechanism
workers first attach the trigger and the
hammer spring to a larger component called
the trigger guard.
Then they connect the hammer itself with a
tight fitting pin.
The Hammer Spring provides the resistance
needed for the hammer to hit the firing pin
hard enough to fire the cartridge after it's
cocked.
Taking the action, they insert the bolt
containing the firing pin, then the firing
pin extension.
This wedge piece links those two components.
They insert the trigger guard into the
action, coaxing it into the correct position
with a few taps of a mallet.
They attach the lever underneath the trigger
guard.
They mount a spring on each side of the
lever to put tension on it.
Then finally they connect the lever to the
firing mechanism with two sets of links to
Cock the Hammer and prepare to pull the
trigger to fire you.
Pull down the lever, then pull it back up.
After firing you move the lever up and down
once again to eject the spent cartridge and
reload and cock for the next shot.
They finish assembling the action by
attaching side plates, one of which has a
side loading gate for inserting the
cartridges.
The action has two threaded holes, one for
attaching the magazine tube that holds the
cartridges and the other for attaching the
barrel.
It's threaded and requires some top filing
in order to meet the very strict
specifications set out by the proof house,
the body responsible for ensuring that
firearms conform to all manufacturing
regulations to attach the barrel to the
action. They lock the barrel in a vise, then
screw the action onto the threaded end.
They use various tools and gauges to ensure
the two parts are perfectly aligned and that
the lever closes completely when pulled up.
Next, they insert what's called a check
cartridge of the appropriate caliber into the
chamber. This checks the internal spacing to
ensure the ammunition feeds correctly and
fires safely.
They mount a temporary stock on the other
end of the action and send the rifle to the
proof house for performance and safety
testing.
Their technicians place it in an enclosed
chamber, load ammunition and fire twice
the proof hose, hand punches, markings onto
the bottom of the rifle.
These markings, recognized by the European
Economic Community, officially certify that
the firearm functions properly and safely.
The gun factory contracts a woodworking
company to produce the rifles stock.
It's made from a block of walnut.
First, workers trace a template that's in
the basic shape of the stalk.
They saw along the trace line.
This gives them a starting form which
computer guided machines then refine a mill,
progressively carves the detailed profile
with a series of different tools.
Then they mount the stock on a lathe which
rotates it against a sander to smooth the
surface and perfect the shape.
The stock has two holes in the back to which
they attach an end piece, the wood shop
stains and varnishes the finished stock and
sends it to the gun factory where workers
attach it to the action.
After that, they mount the magazine tube to
the action.
When you feed cartridges into the side
loading gate, they drop into the magazine
tube. Upon leaving the rifle, a carrier
pushes up one cartridge, which the bolt then
pushes into the chamber, preparing the rifle
to fire.